what is the best way to know if
you have high cortisol what is cortisol
cortisol is the main stress hormone and
if cortisol is too high there's a lot of
problems that could happen in your body
i've done a lot of videos on this
let me go down the list to give you some
ideas on what happens when your cortisol
is too high
you get belly fat you lose protein
in your thigh muscles and your buttocks
okay
so you lose your butt and your thighs
what what's not going to do your knees
it's going to make your knees very
painful and weak especially when you're
climbing stairs your blood pressure
might increase first starting with the
systolic that's the top number
and then ending up with the diastolic 2.
allergies asthma
acne anxiety low tolerance
to stress people start really getting on
your nerves especially
slow drivers inflammation
why because cortisol is the main
anti-inflammatory
so if you don't have it you fill up with
inflammation it could be anywhere back
pain
whatever blood sugar problems you can
even
end up becoming a diabetic if there's
too much cortisol
this is why when people get injected
with prednisone for example
where they use prednisone a lot
sometimes they can become a diabetic
cravings for carbs and breads
okay that would be one way to know that
you have a problem with cortisol
decreased libido decreased potassium
because potassium goes through you
and that's a problem because potassium
is needed for so many things like energy
relaxing you balancing fluids it's a
main electrolyte
etc etc you may tend to hold salts and
that's why you have edema as well
but also you will lose something
that is involved with making acids
okay and hydrochloric acid so you end up
with digestive problems because you
don't have enough acid
and your blood ph can go more on the
alkaline side not the acid side that a
lot of times people think
more alkaline and that can give you a
whole series of
additional problems but in addition to
all these symptoms
one of the best ways to know you have
high cortisol is the time you wake up
at night typically it's going to be
about two o'clock
in the morning it could be a little bit
later like 2 30 a.m
but between 2 and 2 30 a.m in the
morning that's when
you become awake okay now i had this
problem for years and i didn't know what
it was
it was driving me crazy it was torture
because i would get up in the middle of
night
and of course i had restless leg
syndrome too but i just wake up and i
would start to
think and analyze and solve problems and
worry
for hours and then when i finally went
to sleep
that was around eight o'clock so the
pattern
for high cortisol is you wake up at 2
a.m
or 2 30 a.m and then you finally can get
to bed right around 8 a.m when you're
supposed to wake up right
why is that because cortisol follows a
circadian wave
and cortisol normally is supposed to be
the lowest
at 2 a.m okay in the highest at 8 a.m in
the morning
so everything is kind of backwards and
so when you should be sleeping
you're most awake when you should be
awake you're mostly asleep
and then also you might have a problem
with midday right around let's say
um two o'clock p.m or three o'clock
or you just want to take a nap
so that's the pattern of high cortisol
you can also do a
saliva test there's also a hair analysis
i don't know
if they're still doing it now but that's
a really good analysis they check your
hair because if you test your cortisol
with your blood you're only looking at
your
cortisol at one time of the day
as compared to the hair which gives you
an overall average of what's going on
with cortisol or a saliva test which is
good which you're measuring like every
four hours
through a whole period of time to find
out what's happening on this pattern
so the question is what do you do about
it if you have
symptoms of high cortisol well you got
to find out
what or who is causing your stress
do something to improve that okay
walking
long walks in nature very very important
physical work is a little better than
exercise even exercise is really good
but physical work to the point where
you're you can get tired
because it also doesn't just deplete you
of the excess energy the nervous energy
but it gets your attention off problems
b1
essential nutritional yeast is one of
the best sources
and lots of it vitamin d3
vital okay and another reason why
vitamin d is good is because
cortisol tends to block the
storage of vitamin d as well as the
ability to use vitamin d
people with high cortisol usually are
always deficient in vitamin d
and vitamin d is also good for
depression and vitamin d
acts like cortisol in the body with all
the side effects so it's not necessarily
going to give you more cortisol it'll
help you
regulate or balance cortisol that you
already have
potassium magnesium are the two minerals
that are physiological tranquilizers
they're
key minerals that help relax the nervous
system and usually if you have high
cortisol you're going to be
deficient in both of these so taking
those either an electrolyte
or in food is very important and then
apple cider vinegar
why because you have alkalosis and we
need to acidify
the body so then you can start absorbing
the minerals
and breaking down protein very very
important
i have a lot more videos on cortisol
i'll put the links down below but thanks
for watching
hey before you go if you're benefiting
from
any of my content i would love
to hear about your success story please
share it
in the link down below